the major motivation in this opposition
is is kind of a turf war
daelin Dorsey runs an OBGYN Clinic in
Scottsdale Arizona like many doctors she
runs her own independent practice with a
regular client base and a full-time
staff that works under her supervision
but daily endorsee is not a doctor she's
a nurse practitioner I decided to open
up my own practice because I really
wanted to have control over the way that
I provided care I wanted to provide
advanced nursing and working under the
auspices of the physician you're
providing care according to their
guidelines the the medical model and not
so much the nursing model which is a bit
different Arizona is one of 18 states
that allows nurse practitioners to have
their own medical practices they can
treat patients make diagnoses even
prescribe medication all without
oversight from a doctor that big thing
that nurses provide is we're easier to
be educated we can come to the workforce
a lot faster nurse practitioners are
proven to be the quality and cost
effective providers of health care nurse
practitioners across the country are
pushing for the freedom afforded in
Arizona saying it will provide more
low-cost affordable health care at a
time when more people than ever need it
but in some states doctors are pushing
back just as hard their training is very
limited compared to physicians I have by
the time I finished my pediatric
residency Oh 24,000 hours of training
experience that's multiples of what
nurse practitioners have California's
nurse practitioners made a push to
legalize independent practices but were
stopped dead in their tracks thanks in
part to the powerful California Medical
Association SB 491 was eventually killed
in committee and that was basically at
the behest of the California Medical
Association which is the organization
that represents physicians in the state
and the main reason for that is they
wanted to prevent competition from the
nurse practitioners they're not
physicians they lack a certain kind of
experience that I believe is very
important to the safety of patients and
the quality of medical
care that we're providing its true nurse
practitioners do not have the same level
of medical education that a physician
does but I think physicians are probably
a bit over educated for most of what
they do you don't have to have all that
education to provide the most basic of
primary care and that is where nurses
just fit the bill perfectly it would be
risky to assume that just opening the
floodgates to independent practice would
not be without some substantial downside
now I suppose you could do a test and
just see what happens I think that doing
so would put patients at risk luckily we
have done a sort of test in the eighteen
states which already have legalized
independent practice for nurse
practitioners physician groups point to
maps like this and say that nurses
haven't filled in the gaps in
underserved rural areas as promised but
even if that's true a Health Affairs
Survey of 26 published studies showed
that there's no evidence that the
primary care nurse practitioners provide
is in any way inferior or more expensive
than that of physicians in fact patients
actually reported a higher level of
satisfaction with nurse practitioners
there's no studies that show what you're
saying in terms of decreased quality of
care coming from nurse practitioners if
you have if you have an issue a health
issue and you don't go to a mechanic you
have always gone to your physician
there's no evidence that had you gone to
a mechanic there would be a downside on
the other hand that would be a really
bad idea our culture says the most
highly educated person is the only
person that's able to make a diagnosis
and offer a treatment plan but we know
based on the evidence and the literature
research studies prove that that's not
truly the case the licensing laws are
almost always sold as being in the
public interest it's going to protect
public health and safety but in reality
all they do is drive up prices and
reduce competition which reduces the
incentive to provide good services to
the consumer nourish pect
are making physicians a lot of money and
of course they want to keep us under
their control we don't think we're
trying to take over your job we want to
work in conjunction with you and that's
the only way I think that our healthcare
system is going to improve is if
everybody starts working together and
working to the fullest of what they're
capable and able and allowed by
legislation to do